يعني كيف
اي تفسر قدره هذه المسيره على الانطلاق
ربما من اماكن بعيده دون ان تكتشف تصيب
الهدف الذي تريد ان تصيبه
وتوقع خسائر في صفوف الجيش
الامريكي من دون ان تعترضها دفاعات
جويه وهذا سؤال محير للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهه الق
للمسيره التي اخترقت كل الدفاعات ومعروف
ان الدفاعات الامريكيه متطوره وقادره و
ومسيطره على المنطقه ولكن انا بتقديري
هناك ثغرات بالتاكيد لا يوجد لا يوجد سلاح
عسكري في العالم لا يكون له نقاط ضعف او
ثغرات استطاعت الجهه التي ارسلت هذه
المسيره ان تستغل هذه الثغرات وربما انها
يعني في عمليه سابقه
اكتشفت ثغرات واستطاعت ان تتلاش من خلال
تطويرها ومعروف انه كل سلاح هناك سلاح
مضاد وكل قدرات هناك قدرات ايضا مضاده
ولكن هذه المره انا بتقديري يعني كان
الدرس قاسيا على الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وعلى منظوماتها الدفاعيه وعلى
الرديه طيب عاده يعني كانت القواعد
الامريكيه تحديدا في العراق وفي سوريا
ايضا تتعرض لهجمات
بصواريخ او بطائرات مسيره لكن لم يكن يسقط
هذا العدد من القتلى والجرحى الان هل من
تفسير ل سبب سقوط هذا العدد من
اي الضحايا والمصابين في هذه
العمليه يعني بالتاكيد من اختار الهدف كان
كان يرصد هذا الهدف منذ فتره طويله ومعروف
دائما وابدا بنوك الاهداف اي يعني تحتاج
الى يعني ناس الاكفاء لديهم قدرات عقليه
يتابعون ينسقون مع بعض
يرصدون يحاولون يعني اختيار الاهداف التي
يمكن ان تؤثر على من تستهدفه فبالتالي انا
بتقديري بعد التمحيص بعد الرصد بعد التتبع
وجدوا ان هذا
الهدف يمكن تحقيق اصابات فيه اكثر من غيره
وخاصه ان الجغرافيا التي جاءت في هذا
الهدف ربما ساعدت سواء كان الموقع او
الطبي طبيعه المنطقه او كونها يعني موجوده
بين ثلاثه حدود الحدود العراقيه الحدود
السوريه الحدود الاردنيه فبالتالي ربما
يكون هناك عده عوامل يعني اولا
قدره على من اختار هذا الهدف وهناك ايضا
اجراءات في الموقع نفسه هل كانت الاجراءات
في الموقع ماخوذه بعين الاعتبار ام كان
هناك ترهل وعدم انتباه هذه يعني هل هذا
يعود يعود ال الى عامل المفاجاه وعدم توقع
ان يكون هذا المكان
تحديدا
هو هدف
لهذه الطائره باعتبارها للمره الاولى التي
تتعرض
فيه اكيد اكيد يعني عنصر المفاجاه
بالتاكيد هذا الحجم من الجرحى والقتلى
يؤكد بانهم تفاجئوا ان هذه المسيره يعني
وصلت الى النجاح في استخدام عنصر المباغته
والمفاجاه وهناك عوامل اخرى متعدده ربما
يكون عامل الطقس ايضا
ساعد لانه نحن نحن نحن الان في طقس شتاء
هناك غيوم ايضا يعني هذه كلها العوامل
الجغرافيه العوامل الطبيعيه ايضا تساعد
الجنود وكيفيه
تصرفهم الوقت التوقيت طيب الزمان المكان
كل هذه عوامل تساعد في نجاح ا الوصول
للهدف نعم اود الاشاره الى الخبر العاجل
الذي يظهر على شاشتنا كبير الديمقراطيين
بلجنه القوات المسلحه بمجلس مجلس النواب
الامريكي يقول ان ايران لا تريد صراعا
مباشرا معنا ولا اعتقد انها ستصعد ضدنا
اذا يقول كبير الديمقراطيين بلجنه القوات
المسلحه بمجلس النواب الامريكي ان ايران
لا تريد صراعا مباشرا معنا ولا اعتقد انها
ستصعد ضدنا سيد واصف عريقات
ام حرص
المقاومه الاسلاميه في العراق على ان تعلن
بان الطائره انطلقت من سوريا واصابت هدفا
في سوريا كيف
تفهمه يعني اولا الاعلام بحد ذاته هذا
قرار
جريء تتحمل مسؤوليه وانها لدي لديها
القدره على تحمل المسؤوليه مستقبلا لانه
معروف في هيك حاله
بالتاكيد سيكون هناك رد امريكي وهي ليست
المره الاولى المقاومه تحدثت عن
178 اي استهداف سابق ولكل استهداف كان
هناك ردود افعال فبالتالي الاسراع في تحمل
المسؤوليه انا بتقديري هذا قرار جريء وهذا
يعني ان فيه نوع من التحدي بمعنى اننا
قمنا بهذا الهدف ونحن نعرف ان الرد
الامريكي سياتي سريعا وربما
يكون يعني الرد كبيرا او ربما يكون مفاجئا
ولكن ان هم جاهزون يعني حين حين يعلن بهذه
الطريقه بمعنى ان هناك جاهزيه لهذه
المقاومه في تحمل المسؤوليه وفي التصدي
لاي ردود من الجانب الامريكي شكرا جزيلا
لك اللواء الركن المتقاعد واصف عريقات
الخبير في الش العسكريه من رام الله شكرا
جزيلا لك